now since you're a sort of an expert in
zombie apocalypses I wanna I want to
know what your assessment is or your
prediction is if Bobby Bobby survival
rates in a in a apocalyptic situation
involving zombie gotcha
here's how here's how I think it would
go down for Bobby Lee okay can I just
say I'm gonna have my eyes closed your
eyes are closed the reason why my eyes
are closed is because you know I don't
wear it with your eyes I don't know what
I want to hear with my mind okay but I
want you to say I want you to just go
easy and know that I'm sensitive please
move on slowly what are your strengths
and what are his weaknesses here's
here's what you would have to rely on
easy no this is it this is good stuff go
ahead okay
I don't know that you're naturally one
to be the first in line right
what leader naturally yeah I don't think
you're necessarily the one that's gonna
run up and and protect your tribe
correct okay all right I know I know
where you're going good thing we had
your defenses after I'm closing my eyes
again because I'm good do you think you
would be around for a bit mmm because
you're lovable and so the other people
in your tribe would want to and do
anything to protect it there it is
that's what you wanted but that's
whatever it is to stay alive right yeah
and if that's it if it's recognizing no
no no I'm good to the tribe you know is
the community better off with me there
are you use your app or am i a rat you
think I would [ __ ] people over I survive
oh I don't you know know the youth same
but see that's the other reason that
you're gonna be protected you're gonna
be shielded because that's that is
currency in the apocalypse that is
loyalty is Lawrence currency yeah
yeah loyalties loving it so that's good
no what was really concerning to me was
no not about us about how I'm gonna dine
the apocalypse again oh yeah my but
that's that's I'm not a professional
Lois I just think he can't run past 11
seconds oh I didn't think I could either
until I got on this show there we go
thank you
so I mean there's there's hope for Bobby
in the apocalypse that he's he would
actually he would actually find things
in himself that he didn't even know that
he had now do you think good people last
longer define good in the apocalypse I
mean because that's the thing do people
who are generous kind and with without
ability to manipulate can they survive
in them or do you need to be
manipulative and a little bit strategic
and a little dust not enough to be kind
that's right it's just not enough you
know that that helps in your your
smaller core group your you know your
your nucleus but then there's this
broader world and it's just you can't
you know what are you gonna do be nice
to a walker that's coming up like I bet
you're real pretty when you see that
Klaus is one day really I got it yeah
you know but kindness its it's a lovely
thing but it's not gonna save you
oh man I should have been throwing
cliches every boy I mean that's the way
I learned that on MADtv
how do we keep him with the conversation
no good great okay so yeah no but um you
know my Minnesota nice cuz that's a
thing Minnesota nice yeah bazillion
t-shirts up there and it's true people
from Minnesota in general are very nice
and that does not serve you you know
always like I I I used to have to go to
to I wasn't good at asserting myself on
the show because it I felt unkind doing
it they were gonna be a [ __ ] and at the
same time it's like there are things
happening sometimes that I didn't think
were right you know as far as my path on
the show and so I would but when I would
get mad my tendency when I in
confrontation is to cry and I didn't
want to cry sometimes but I didn't want
to so I go into [ __ ] Sookie's office
and instead of the usual which had
started where I would get mad and cry I
got rid of that method and I would all
I'd have to do is go in and tap my foot
down yeah and and then we'd bust out
laughing because that was me putting my
foot down literally like we'd laugh
about it yeah then it opened up the door
for me to just talk about the thing and
not you know it was just a method yeah
when you bring his name up and and I
just what I've never really ever talk
about [ __ ] of Jim but I want to say
that what a blessing it was to have him
as my boss I'm so glad you went that
route because I feel the same one of the
kind yeah I love him so much he's fair
yeah and the one night I remember when I
was on the
chopping block and I did one line
Kristen Yamaguchi or something some sort
of skaters whatever name is not Michelle
cool so I mean the silver like [ __ ]
sequins drugs and I've rolled a roller
skates on and I'm just gonna skateboard
into a scene with Adam Carolla and Jimmy
Kimmel okay and so I just I skated in
the line as funniest as I could yeah and
I got a huge laugh was from a live
audience
uh and said I remember dick live turning
around to the riders go right for him
he's funny him screaming let's hear him
say that yes absolute and I remember
skating away right going you know me
feeling really good about myself in that
very moment because I was drowning on
that show you know and that was the
night where I went I think dick might
like me yeah I like him yeah I hold a
very special place in my heart for him
yeah and I don't understand why people
would even have a bad thing because say
because at the end of the day he's not
like your typical sure runners where
I've had I've seen executive producers
that were made differently he's a little
bit more non confrontational you know
and every me that was also something
that was um not that great about him
because you know you could hold
resentments toward him or whatever but
um but at the end of the day you can
tell that he was a sweet man so sweet
yeah and so and he's got a job that's
like I can only imagine yeah you know
yeah yeah it's so sweet that you're here
you know and okay let's be clear about
this okay shut the [ __ ] up lady I'll rip
your eyes now that I know you know you
know what you are and you can't [ __ ]
sleep through it so color on the inside
you live through it
and own up own up to it what did I I did
I just said I'm a white lady full of
color I know special you can remind I'm
like that why can't I'm not good I don't
know I don't know cliche I [ __ ] you
George
[Music]